could you please speak to them potential
medical
applications um yeah so again one of our
design uh specifications was uh that we
want to use this in medicine and uh like
Angela was talking about having them be
vile type was really important for us um
so we not sort of inserting any foreign
DNA that could when in turn deployed in
the human body could have of Target
effects so for that reason it was
important for us to keep the human DNA
while type so we've tried from more than
20 different human donors and in every
single time we're able to create an anth
robobot and um that's across a lot of
different ages um and you know genders
and races and we've seen that this works
with a lot you know diverse like human
genomes um so what sort of more
specifically in the medical field that
we are hoping to accomplish is can we
take a uh self from a human donor so
currently as we mentioned we're taking
this from the human air epithelium but
down the line you can Envision taking a
cell from a human uh patient skin and
then uh turning it into a induced plop
poent stem cell which in turn would
basically revert the clock and have the
ability to then be differentiated into
all these different kinds of tissues in
the human body including the human lung
so in terms of application that's what
we're envisioning that's not something
we've shown in the paper but that
protocol has already been worked out in
the literature um so starting with a
human skin cell and then turning it into
an into an anthrop that is uh geared
towards a specific application based on
what that patient might need uh and then
when we put that into the body it's it
is a synthetic construct it's something
that doesn't um you know there's no such
thing as an INR in the human body it is
a synthetic construct it has a new
architecture but it has the exact same
genome as as that patient so the body
won't recognize it as a or that's our
current hypothesis um as a as a foreign
object and won't like trigger immune
system and inflammation yeah I was going
to ask about if you all have tested
biocompatibility or immunogenicity if
you're already envisioning it for
medical
applications uh not yet our preliminary
experiments have been with human cells
but in vitro only so uh next step for us
would be xvivo tissue so human cells
extracted from humans and then after
that it would be um invivo or proxies
for invivo um experiments so that would
be step
three yeah but the but you know the I
mean these cells are already coming from
the they've already been inside the
patient so so while while we haven't
specifically tested the IM
immunogenicity in dvo the chances are
very high that it's going to work I mean
these are these are the idea is
personalized medicine it's a
bespoke kind of um construct that's made
of each patient's own cells so it's
likely fine and I I just I want to um I
just want to underscore the amazing the
the thing that just just blows my mind
every time I think about it you know
that last figure in that in that paper
is basically showing Just One initial
thing that we found that that these guys
can do which is to to help um neurons
heal across a scratch wound in in
two-dimensional culture just just to
think about that the tracheal cells are
sitting in your body and they sort of
sit there quietly for decades doing
their thing and and and using their
cilia to waft little particles and mucus
and stuff up you know out of your lungs
the fact that if if uh uh liberated from
their environment then given a chance to
kind of re reboot their their their
multicellularity they now have the
ability to go around and uh repair
defects in other types of cells like we
would have never known that it's just
amazing to me that that that they have
that capacity and it and it makes Mak me
wonder what what else you know what
other cells are sitting around the your
your body with capacities to to heal
other components and to have other
beneficial you know pro- regenerative
types of uh uh outcomes on different
parts of the body like that that idea of
releasing the um the native healing
potential of your own cells and letting
them do new things that might be
beneficial for the body I think I I
think is incredibly powerful I think
we're just seeing the first glimpses of
that here can you talk about how this
fits into the larger framework of your
work because as I heard gazm say take a
skin cell and turn it into a PL poent
cell it reminds me of our previous
conversations yeah yeah um there's a few
uh
the the the kind of applications of
these are are in several different
directions on the one hand we certainly
want to use this for very specific
practical purposes so we think that um
once we gain uh a better understanding
of their kind of native functions and
and a little bit better on the
programming end we will be able to
address all sorts of very specific
conditions and we can sort of run down
some of the early ideas that that that
we have but there's a bigger picture
here which is uh using the using this
this biotics platform as a kind of a
simplified um model system in which to
crack the morphogenetic code uh think
about all of the problems of biom
medicine including birth defects uh
traumatic injury or or thus failing to
heal from traumatic injury cancer
degenerative disease all of these things
have one thing in common which is that
they would go away if we had the ability
to tell groups of cells what to build
right that's that's the major uh rate
limiting step for regenerative medicine
is that we do not understand how
cellular collectives make decisions
we're pretty good on the hardware side
for individual cells right so we know
how cells differentiate we know what the
what the various um lots of various
genes do and and how they interact with
each other and so on but but this this
idea of how do collections of cells make
decisions that they're going to make a
hand versus a foot versus something else
and more importantly how we communicate
our patterning goals to them that is if
you want to build a new organ or you
want to repair an existing organ or you
want to make something that has never
existed before what information do you
need to give to these CES and what
interface can you use to get your your
your goals across to the uh to the
cellular Collective and that I think is
is critically important for locking the
promise of regenerative medicine and so
that's that's what we're starting off
here because you really have to uh under
before you can you can use all these
fancy programming techniques and that
includes not just the traditional Sy bio
that people are using but also the stuff
that we do in our lab which is
bioelectrical um kinds of communication
with networks and so on you really need
to understand what are the Baseline
plasticities and competencies of these
cells what do they already know how to
do and why why do they make decisions
and uh to uh uh take specific paths
through anatomical space and build
specific kinds of anatomies and so on
and so I think that's you know in the
greater scheme of our lab's work which
is to understand how to communicate with
the collective intelligence of cells
this is a very important uh model system
in which we can now ask okay what kinds
of stimuli what kinds of information can
we be giving to these cells to get them
to build various things much like with
the zenbot you know these first papers
uh were all about characterizing their
background own kind of native
competencies we didn't engineer the heck
out of them with new genes and all this
stuff we we we can and we probably will
in the future but step one is to
understand how do collections of sales
make decisions about what they're going
to do Michael can you also indicate
again these are two different papers
here that have an overarching theme but
outline how are they distinct and how
are they the same so one has to do with
anth robots or biobots and then the
other has to do with this embryonic
communication and the resilience so
please yeah the the the the com well
there there are many common themes but
one one important one is collective
decision- making so it's again this idea
of so so in the case of the anthropo
it's a question of understanding how
groups of normal cells with normal human
um genome derived molecular Hardware are
going to decide to work together to uh
make a specific new coherent construct
with with new Behaviors new new
functionalities and so on in the case of
Angela this is uh and the um and the
cross embryo morphogenetic assistance
it's the idea that standard
developmental biology studies how cells
cooperate to make a a nice embryo well
it turns out that there's this actually
works on a higher level as well so
groups of embryos also work together to
complete morphogenesis and in both of
these cases what we want to understand
is where is the information what is the
collective intelligence of these cells
what are they a what kind of problems
are they able to solve so in the case of
the
able to um uh uh they find themselves in
the new environment in a new kind of new
scenario and they're able to put
together a very coherent uh form that is
able to to live for weeks and and and
have certain functions and so on in the
CA in in Angela Case what you're seeing
is again a kind of collective problem
solving but this time at the level of
whole animals so not down at the
cellular level which is standard
developmental biology it's kind of you
know maybe this is the beginnings of a
kind of uh sort of um hyper
developmental ol where what you're
really trying to work out is the rules
by which whole bodies communicate to
better achieve better solve the problem
of of of embryogenesis because one of
the things that well many people have
studied in our lab focuses on in
particular is uh in biological
intelligence in the sense of problem
solving that means when you're
confronted with a new scenario that you
haven't seen before especially a new
scenario that you haven't seen before uh
are you able to complete your goals in
in case of of development are you able
to uh make the target morphology that um
that that you want to make you know a
correct embrya or some other functional
thing in the case of in the case of
anthr robots and so that's what what
that's what we're seeing in both of
these uh in both of these projects we're
seeing new unexpected competencies at
different levels at the level of cells
and then at the level of organisms uh to
do something um helpful and coherent in
novel circumstances if you enjoyed that
clip then the full podcast is out right
now you can click around here enjoy
subscribe to theories of everything to
get notified of upcoming podcasts as
there are new full length podcasts every
week on the topics of mathematics
physics Consciousness Free Will and
AI